So let's blow up our sampling distribution a little bit. So we have three
critical regions. The smallest one has a probability greater than this z score
of 0.01, and this z score here is 3.08. And remember that the middle of the
distribution, the mean, has a z score of zero. Then our second smallest
critical region is point zero one. So that's the probability of being greater
then this value, which you found was about two point three two. And then our
biggest critical region is point zero five. So that's the probability greater
than a z score of 1.65. The z scores corresponding to these alpha levels are
called the z critical values. So we'll find our sample mean. Calculate the z
score, and the distribution of sample means, or the sampling distribution. And
then look to see where this mean falls. Let's say it falls in the critical
region, any of them, that means it's unlikely. If it falls out here in the
green region or the smallest critical region, we'll report the smallest alpha
level, because that means our sample statistics are really different from the
population parameters. And therefore there's strong evidence of an effect from
whatever treatment was imposed. For example, say we take some sample mean from
some sample size n and then we calculate the z score. So remember we subtract
the mu and then divide by the standard deviation of the sampling distribution.
And let's say that we get the z score is 1.82. We would say that this is
significant at p less than 0.05. And that's because if we look at where this
z-score falls on the distribution, it falls in between 1.65 and 2.32. So this
z-score, 1.82, is somewhere in this red region. Meaning that the probability of
having obtained this sample mean is less than 0.05. But it's not less than
0.01. So it's only significant at probability, or p, less than 0.05. And
remember 0.05 is the alpha level.